let's talk about a character that does
not change within a story versus a
character that does change within a
story I'll take a hypothetical let's say
we have a female she's 30 years old she
lives at home with her parents she's a
bartender she makes great money and
meets many interesting people but her
character does not evolve or change in
any way well let's say that her change
needs to be let's make it a personal
story let's say that she doesn't have
love okay so she's wounded
most great Hollywood movies are about a
wounded hero given a chance to change
okay that's what they are so let's say
that the reason she's wounded is that
her wound and it's always about a wound
in a story that's any good we all have
wounds I call them core wounds our
parents usually gave them too so let's
say that her wound is that she can't
connect to anybody okay
she can't be intimate with anybody she
just doesn't feel it so she's a
bartender so really she doesn't have to
ever have intimate relationships
she just has lots of relationships with
the people at the bar but they never go
any further than that okay if she has
any intimacy at all well she doesn't and
she's not intimate with her family
either okay so what's gonna change or
what's gonna make her change well you
have people who are gonna tear her wound
wider open let's say that that's the
owner of the bar who doesn't want her to
change at all loves the way she is
and and and tells her now though that
hey we're changing our bar our bar is
gonna become a coffee house and it's
coming really important that you talk to
the people who come in that's gonna be
as a barista you I want you to really
establish friendships and it's all about
that and by the way here comes someone
who's a consultant who's going to help
you change and be more friendly and also
more intimate with the clients well she
really will hate that she'll hate that
she'll want to quit but she can't quit
she makes so much money doing this so
then you're gonna have also a person on
the other side you're gonna have a let's
call her an impact carrot who's a
relative who says to her hey your
sister's getting married
making this a personal story your
sisters getting married and your sister
wants you to come to the wedding and she
also wants you to help me make this card
up that that it's a whole family and
everybody's in it and our heroine
resists that too not I want to do that
at all and I don't want to be involved
in the family I don't even know these
people
so right there you have this personal
setup where you have a girl with a core
wound as I can't be intimate and you
have her put in a position where she's
going to be forced to have to be
intimate or she's gonna wind up in a
tragedy and then you give a villain into
the story and the villain is a guy who
is just as disconnected from people as
she is and he tells her you know what
let's just have sex nothing else knowing
i'ma see it all and she says great
that's fantastic my dreams but as we get
into the second hand she begins to fall
in love with this guy and she also
begins to realize when she's in that bar
that she's beginning to feel the lack of
intimacy and and it's hurting her that
she can't connect to people so she's
learning from this person who's there as
a consultant how to connect because
she's bonding with her at the same time
she's falling in love with this villain
who is gonna now tell her when she
reaches out to him I don't want to be
with you in fact I've got a family so
goodbye that's gonna push her to change
to heal to reach out to understand she
needs intimacy so in the third act the
third act will be all about her helping
her sister's wedding
reaching out when her sisters say goes
into crisis and says suddenly I have
cold feet I don't want to get married
now our heroines gonna have to minister
to her and say wait a minute I think you
should because intimacy is good I just
learned it's good and I'm gonna tell you
one of the times in your life you've
been happiest haven't they been with
other people so she's actually learned
through pain and learned through the
fact of being rejected by someone just
like her a mirror that she does need
intimacy that she does need to reach out
and be with people now that's a very
small story very emotional intimate
story in the end
she reaches out to her family but she
doesn't have to fall in love this is an
indie movie this is a cool kind of movie
all she has to have is a small change to
her understanding
I need Emma see I mean and in fact
that's the story of up in the air
that's a very famous movie with George
Clooney it's all about and it's a
character study it's just about this guy
who's disconnected from people who by
being pushed by villains and also pushed
by helpers learns how to become
connected to people that's now if it was
a superhero story or if was a tragedy in
the end she wouldn't learn that she
wouldn't have a change she tried to
change but then because she fell in love
with someone who was a bad teacher she
would be so crushed that in the end she
retreats and decides she's not gonna
love she's gonna go back to the bar and
there's no movement at all that's a
tragedy in fact that's the story of the
wrestler that was a great movie a few
years ago Christ's change looks like
they're gonna change but has a mentor
that's so bad that when the mentor
rejects them and moves away they simply
fall back into their old patterns and in
the wrestler he goes back to wrestling
and he dies so you can build the story
either way it's all about who's there on
the journey with them impacting them
that tells you and shows you and then
whether or not they're going to be able
to heal and change or if they're going
to fall back into a tragic end
you